uh a sort of a beef
hey blanco can you help me understand
i'm glad you're asking this i know just
as much as you do charlie puth speaks
out about his supposed feud with benny
blanco that's a good headline for you
guys that's attention grabbing in case
you missed it over the last few months
benny posted a bunch of tick tock videos
aimed at the attention singer and let's
just say they aren't so nice
like
at all
i really do have to finish this song
what if it starts i really do have to
shut the [ __ ] up charlie you don't have
to finish this song nobody gives a sh
i'm gonna pick a scene that gets a light
switch and she's like a common thing
around the house and then i'm gonna like
record it and like it's gonna be so
spaniard oh i'm such a loser the lyrics
wait are you actually just making these
videos for me with you at this point are
you just that much of a loser i can't
tell this song you literally just said
i'm a loser
yeah
like i said
not so nice and all that has fans
totally confused because the two work
together like on charlie's 2019 single i
warned myself
and they were super friendly when they
did an instagram live together back in
2020. oh
we're doing what we
always do in private and
in front of a lot of [ __ ] people some
fans even think the feud could be fake
or a prank or some sort of publicity
stunt but in a new interview with carson
and kennedy talk with famous people on
mix 104.1 charlie says he's just as
confused as we are i know just as much
as you do
i was going to ask if you knew
if
anything else i thought we were friends
but i mean what the hell do i know i'm
so
in my head on i'm on another planet i
don't remember what i had for lunch
yesterday if there's not a song or a
beat attached to it but
i i my answer is i
think we're your friends thank you for
answering i i think every i think
everything's okay i think i'll just
back in november charlie addressed benny
directly on tick tock posting this video
alongside the caption quote i finally
had to say something you know man these
videos were really funny at first um i
don't exactly know why you've been so
mean to me these past couple of months
but it does genuinely hurt my feelings i
used to look up to you and
i don't know where all this is coming
from
and the 33 year old music producer
wasted no time responding i know why i
made this video because you're a [ __ ]
loser booth look at you you sit in a
room all day and make tick tocks and
tell people
dude what the hell is wrong with you
look at your hair it looks like you got
a toupee or a wig on or something get a
grip and get a [ __ ] haircut
flash forward to early january and get
this billy eilish jumped in the mix to
defend charlie legit dropping the mic
with
this what do you do all day buddy
the same thing
literally the same thing that's all i'd
say to be honest with you the 30 year
old singer was grateful billy had his
back
i'm speechless
and slid into the comments of the grammy
winners post writing simply thank you
but even that burn from billy hasn't
stopped benny from continuing to slam
charlie regardless the four-time grammy
nominee seems to be thriving it's my
pleasure making music after months of
teasing new music on tick-tock tick-tock
i love that he finally dropped the music
video for his latest single light switch
and it's a bop
it's
rocking your body
[Music]